When you think about romance and sweethearts
and spouses, one of the most striking observations
from the research – it's sad, but it's true
– is that, often, married couples will treat
each other with less consideration than they
show to their friends, or even to strangers.
And when I read this, I thought, oh my gosh,
can that be true?
And I realized, of course it's true, because
the people that we're married to are so familiar
to us, they are so close to us; they are really
part of our lives, and it's very easy to take
them for granted or to make them the brunt
of a bad mood or a short temper, and to forget
to use our consideration, our good manners,
our gentle language.
And so one of the things that I remind myself
of all the time is that I want to show as
much consideration to my husband as I would
to any passing stranger or friend.
And I also try to remind myself to show my
husband as much or more affection as my dog,
because when my husband comes and goes from
the apartment, I want to give him a real hello
and a real goodbye.
I want to give him a kiss and a hug and really
look him in the eye and say that I'm glad
to see him.
If my dog can do it, I can do it.